Congress passed an emergency spending
bill last night to keep the federal
government open for two more weeks
it gives lawmakers until December 22nd
to reach a long-term deal that is just
one issue members want to address before
the upcoming holiday break another major
challenge is tax reform next week the
House and Senate may meet to settle
differences between their respective
bills South Dakota Senator John Thune is
one of eight Republican senators named
to the tax reform conference committee
to negotiate the legislation senator
good morning good to have you here it's
nice to be with you let me first ask you
about our new CBS News poll because it
shows that that Americans see these tax
cuts as overwhelmingly benefiting
corporations and the wealthy in fact
nearly two-thirds of Americans thinks
that corporations won't use the tax cut
in order to hire people and create jobs
do you have assurances from big
businesses that they're gonna reinvest
in workers well all the analysis that
we've seen Norah suggests that it may
vary how much they put back into the
business how much they pay out and
distribute dividends or how much they
plow into raising wages and benefits but
it's some amount and if you use 25
percent or 75 percent you get a
different number but all the analysis
that has been done suggests that
reducing the corporate rate the business
rate a lot of that money is going to
flow back into higher wages and so we've
seen as much as $4,000 per household in
this country in terms of the the wage
impact of lowering the business rates
well you've even suggested to
corporations that they could use the tax
cut money to give workers a raise all
workers think that's a really great idea
but we've already heard some
corporations they know they're gonna
pass it on to the shareholders is there
anything that can be done are you trying
to do anything to convince the
corporations you know this might be a
good thing
well I course will encourage it Yael I
don't in a free-market economy obviously
they're gonna make that decision but we
think that if it if they distribute it
in the form you know of dividends to
shareholders that's getting back into
the economy that's gonna benefit a lot
of pension funds a lot of retirement
funds but but we think a lot of it will
go back to workers I mean any company
that sees their tax burden reduced by
that amount is if they want to grow and
expand their operation going to have to
hire more workers and in a competitive
labor market we think that raises wages
for for worker
this country and clearly so many of
these issues are partisan one that's not
is the Children's Health Insurance
Program chip it has bipartisan approval
there's actually a new paper out this
morning in an op-ed in The New York
Times from a bipartisan group of
Governors saying please save kids health
care that fund ran out last September
it's expected to run out nationwide by
early next year if it's not replenished
13,000 children alone in your state are
affected by this 9 million in the
country as a whole
why can't Congress at least come
together when it comes to providing
health care for our youngest and we will
I mean that is something that everybody
agrees upon the chip program is actually
something that got authorized I think my
first year in Congress but it has broad
bipartisan support and my guess is it
will hitch a ride on whatever the year
in spending bill is that we do as you
know it in my state for example the
impact isn't going to be felt to early
next year so we got a little bit of a
window here but I think it'll get done
in the next couple of weeks
a lot of worried families out right let
me ask you this because we did some an
analysis on the median household income
in your state of South Dakota where the
average income is about $50,000 a year
right so that person would pay about 1.4
percent less in taxes the wealthiest
though one percent of South Dakotans
would pay nearly four percent less
that's based on the Senate tax plan so
what would you say to the to the middle
class citizen in South Dakota who says
why are they getting a bigger cut well
if you look at north at you know for
example the Tax Foundation has done an
analysis of an average family in my
state and they've shown that the the tax
cut would be about $2,500 per family but
I just ask people you know sit down and
look at your own tax circumstances plug
in your numbers into your tax return if
you double the standard deduction if you
double the child tax credit if you get
the benefit of the lower rates
you know it's an average family of four
with the combined annual income of
seventy three thousand dollars a year is
going to see a reduction of about twenty
two hundred dollars and that represents
a 60% reduction over what they're paying
under current law so everybody's
circumstances are gonna be different but
if you're on the lower end of the income
scale with that doubling of the standard
deduction I think you're gonna see a
dramatically
and I get you're trying to simplify the
tax code but for what about the people
that are losing the deductions that they
count on state and local taxes medical
expenses the student loan interest I
mean all of those could really hit
people well there will be fewer itemized
errs because of theirs although many of
those deductions that you mentioned are
kept in the Senate version of that bill
so if you want to itemize you can still
take charitable you can still take
mortgage interest you can still take
medical expenses above a certain amount
and so those those could if you choose
to itemize you can still take advantage
of that I think where most people are
going to experience the benefit is with
the reduction in rates I think you're
gonna see a real lowering of rate
particularly you know and if you look at
the Senate bill and how that flows
through the different income categories
but you know everybody's tax
circumstances are different and so I
just encourage people to sit down and
kind of figure out what the the impacts
are for them and their families address
you can address the concerns of adding
to the deficit because they will add to
the deficit over a trillion dollars and
I know the numbers are not final but we
had senator Bernie Sanders here
yesterday I know he's on the opposite
political spectrum of you he's making
the case to that once these tax cuts to
go through that in order to balance the
budget that there will be coming cuts in
Medicare and Social Security can you
guarantee that those cuts won't be made
well I what I would guarantee is that if
we make reforms and we do need to make
reforms to make entitlement programs
sustainable that those are those are
going to be reforms that might for
example say lessen the the rate of
growth and some of those programs over
time but one of the ways that you deal
with the deficit in the debt is you get
a faster growing economy and we've got a
really sluggish economy if we get the
economy growing at even two and a half
percent as opposed to one and a half to
two which is what we've seen for the
last decade then you're gonna get more
government revenue for every one
percentage point increase in GDP it
generates about three trillion dollars
in additional revenue over a decade so
one of the ways to deal with the problem
that Bernie's identified is yes we've
got to restrain spending but we got to
get faster growth and you accomplish
that by reforming our tax code and
making this an attractive place just
turn to the resignation of Al Franken
yesterday he said it's it's not the
irony is not lost on him that the man
who was bragged on tape about his
history of sexual assault now sits in
the Oval Office what do you say to that
now that it looks like
or might be coming to Senate well I mean
I think there are there are men across
all kinds of different industries that
are learning that there are consequences
to bad behavior and I think that's a
good thing you know what happened
yesterday is unfortunate in the Senate
but I think on Capitol Hill the
discussion that we're having right now
is long overdue yes and I think what it
points out is that action is needed you
know we can't continue to accept the
status quo there or anywhere else for
that matter you had called for a Roy
Moore to step aside that is not that
clearly is not the case what will you
all do if he's elected well I think the
one thing I've said all along is if he
comes to Washington he'll immediately be
under an ethics cloud probably an ethics
investigation the result of which could
be recommending expulsion could be
recommending censure there are different
things that the ethics committee
committee can conclude but it's a huge
distraction I mean is the the simplest
wisest thing for him to do in the best
interest of the country and our party is
to step aside and allow another
Republican to get into that race because
I think we would win the seat and yet
the RNC's are supporting him well and
that's an ad that's unfortunate I I
don't condone that I think they made the
right move in the first place all right
very good you could have very good with
you all thank you very good person yeah
person as you do on TV yeah crazy do
[Laughter]